the great states of texas and arizona
have been bussing migrants from the
border to liberal sanctuary cities for
months now but recently texas added a
new destination for migrants chicago the
first bus arrived earlier this week and
the city's mayor was not too happy about
it take a look
with these continued political stunts
governor abbott has confirmed what
unfortunately many of us
had already known
that he is a man without any morals
humanity
or shame
in a statement to fox news a
spokesperson for abbott simply asked
where lightfoot's outrage was when
president biden flew migrants all over
the country in the middle of the night
meanwhile in the state of nevada where
open borders are also a big issue a new
poll shows close races for governor and
senator in the state thanks in part to a
collapse of support for democrats among
hispanics in fact republican candidate
and former state attorney general adam
laxalt finds himself in a virtual tie
with the incumbent democrat senator
catherine cortez matso in a head-to-head
race and joining us now is in fact that
man adam laxalt adam thank you for being
here you know as an american
it doesn't matter which which state we
live in uh we we care about all of
what's happening crime is matters to all
of us schooling matters to all of us and
yet we do see this is important to see
the hypocrisy here the remarkable
reaction of lori lightfoot to to simply
people who have asked to go to chicago
being in a bus and she smears
governor abbott when since she's been
elected adam in 2019 to 2022 murders
have increased 34 percent and she says
greg abbott is the man with no shame and
who's immoral uh what do you think is
going on with uh lori lightfoot at this
point what's her problem
yeah look how about she call out
president biden and while while we're at
it how about senator masto call out
president biden for this open border
this is what's causing massive misery in
this country record spikes in fentanyl
you know i'm in a rural town of elko
nevada right now and they're being
overrun with fentanyl overdoses these
are our children and law enforcement our
good sheriff here ital he can't handle
this stuff without support from the
federal government and for these mayors
to complain that it's finally hitting
their cities
when states like mine and communities
like elk nevada have been dealing for
for many years is absolutely
preposterous and outrageous you know she
is it almost seems like deflection but
this is what is so ghoulish about this
she knows that she has set up her city
as a sanctuary city that's a very
important word they have incentives for
people to come taxes are high she won by
like over 75 when she was elected so the
people of chicago embrace these policies
but the moment it's like acted on
she gets she gets angry it's as though
she's
either trying to hide or she never meant
it and that this was all fake
this is the world we live in every day
look at president biden's speech last
night
he didn't mention
fentanyl overdoses the open border the
the crashing economy
record highs in inflation what did he do
he created a whole new narrative and
smeared half of americans this is what
they do they denigrate people they
attack people they try to deflect from
their terrible policies that are
wrecking my great state and wrecking
wrecking cities all across america
excellent point he said nothing about
the crisis hitting every single american
no matter what party they're in or what
state they live in adam excellent great
thanks for that perspective i appreciate
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else